KORY JEFFREY: Hello everybody.
We are in San Francisco
at Founder World.
Joining me in the
studio today is
Chenoa, the managing
director for Blue Startups.
Welcome.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Thank you.
KORY JEFFREY: So let's
start with the fact
that you are managing
director of a VC in Hawaii.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Yes, I know.
It's tough.
KORY JEFFREY: It's awesome.
It actually sounds
like a dream job.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
It kind of is, yeah.
We call it startup
paradise in Hawaii.
And we're lucky to
live there and we're
lucky to be able to do this work
with exciting tech companies
there.
KORY JEFFREY: So can
you talk a little bit
about the Hawaii tech scene?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Yeah.
So I would describe
it as burgeoning.
It is a smaller scene, but
it's very vibrant and growing.
So it's an exciting time for us.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
And so what's the investment
thesis of your guys' fund?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
So Blue Startups
does a couple different things.
Obviously, we invest
in local companies
that we think have
strong technology
and a good foundation
for success.
And then we also
invest in companies
in a few different areas that we
focus on outside of Hawaii, so
connections to Asia.
We do have strong
connections there.
We look at companies
from the US that
are trying to get
into Asia or companies
from Asia that are trying
to enter the US market.
That's one sweet spot for us.
The other is really
in travel technology.
Since we have a huge
travel industry,
we can access very
high level executives
there in the travel space.
KORY JEFFREY: So playing
on your natural strengths
in location and economy.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Yep.
KORY JEFFREY: And so do you guys
have a certain stage that you
like to invest in?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
It's very early
stage, although we do take in
companies at multiple stages.
Our Hawaii-based companies
tend to be earlier.
Most of the
companies we bring in
tend to be a little later stage,
post-revenue, early traction,
that sort of thing.
KORY JEFFREY: What
does the life cycle
funding look like in Hawaii?
Do they then have
to go somewhere else
to get the later stage?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: So we have
a very robust accelerator,
pre-seed, and seed market there.
So we can get a company all
the way from idea, essentially,
through almost to
Series A. But once they
get to the Series B,
generally speaking,
they have to look
outside for funding.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: But
we're working on that.
Hopefully, eventually, we'll
be able to fund companies
all the way through
their life cycle.
KORY JEFFREY: That's cool.
And so do you find
that helps keep people,
that you have this investment
arm in Hawaii that helps
keep people on the island?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
Oh yeah, absolutely.
And I think that we can
give our entrepreneurs
the best possible start in
life right now in Hawaii.
We can surround them
with amazing mentors.
We can give them funding.
We can give them
everything that they
need for success right now.
It's a very robust
ecosystem at that stage.
It's the later
stages that things
get a little bit tougher.
But, you know, that's
where Silicon Valley
is a specialist at that.
So it's hard to
compete with that
and we shouldn't really try.
KORY JEFFREY: That makes sense.
So we're at Founder World.
There's thousands of
people walking around.
What attracted
you to this event?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
Well, I thought
it was really interesting
that it was going to be free.
Wow, that's amazing.
Who's going to show up for that?
How many people are
going to be here?
There's a lot of people here.
So I've had a chance to
interact with a lot of folks.
I like the focus on founders.
That's really cool.
I think they did a poll of
the audience earlier today.
Who has a startup out there?
It was like everybody.
So that's really
neat that that's
the majority of the folks here.
They're actually
starting a company.
They're really
eager to talk to you
about what they're working on.
A lot of good ideas.
A lot of really
interesting companies.
KORY JEFFREY: Have you had a
chance to walk around the floor
and see any of the demos?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: I have.
I walked around.
I talked to a lot of these guys.
Some really great things
going on out there.
KORY JEFFREY: Is there anything
in particular that kind of
stuck out to you?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
That stuck out to me.
That's interesting.
I just actually was talking
to a company in the mentorship
session called GrowX, I
believe it was called.
They have an indoor growing
facility for tomatoes.
[LAUGHTER]
KORY JEFFREY: That's
not where I thought
you were going with that.
I thought we were going
to go to Colorado.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Yeah.
Obviously, there's other
applications for it.
They're showing
me their pictures
and I'm like, tomatoes?
Interesting.
Is there anything else
that could possibly
be grown in there?
KORY JEFFREY: You
know, beans, tomatoes.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: But
very energy efficient
and that sort of thing.
So that's interesting.
KORY JEFFREY: That's cool.
And you were on
stage today speaking?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: I was.
KORY JEFFREY: And so
what was the message
you were getting across?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
So we were talking
about trends in early
stage seed investing,
kind of where we see
the market headed.
I think a couple trends
came out of that discussion.
One, the internationalization
of the market.
And obviously, with our
east west orientation,
we think about that a lot.
We are interacting
a lot with folks
that are from other
countries, either as investors
or entrepreneurs, primarily
the Asian countries.
So I think that's a trend
that's very interesting.
You have a few
seed stage funders,
like 500 Startups and
them that are really
looking at a very
international kind of play.
And I think we'll see
more and more of that.
I read a great
quote this morning,
which was that Silicon Valley
is no longer a geography.
It's an attitude.
And that can be exported.
And that attitude
and that ecosystem
that's being developed here
that this is the home of
is now being exported
around the world.
And you see different
startup communities really
take hold of that and
make it their own.
You see that in Honolulu, too.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
So if you had to give some
advice to the inspiring
founders, what would it be?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Work on
your monetization strategy.
KORY JEFFREY: It's
a very VC answer.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Sorry.
KORY JEFFREY: That's good.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: We're still
really-- we struggle with that,
I think as the culture
here in the startup world.
Everyone wants to talk
about their product.
That's what I heard
today a lot over and over
and over, the product,
the product, the product.
How are you going to make money?
That age old question.
It never really goes away.
KORY JEFFREY: It never does.
Probably never will.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: I hope so.
We're in trouble if it does.
KORY JEFFREY: That's right.
And I guess my last
question would be,
do you have a favorite
Google technology?
CHENOA FARNSWORTH:
A Google technology?
KORY JEFFREY: Yes.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: Oh gosh.
I use everything
Google all the time,
so how do I narrow it down?
I don't want to be
boring, but I guess Gmail.
KORY JEFFREY: You
would be surprised
how many Gmail answers.
It's been Gmail,
Sheets, and Maps
have been probably the
most popular answer I've
been getting at this event.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: I mean, Gmail
kind of does it all for me.
KORY JEFFREY: This is it.
It kind of comes to the whole
ubiquity of running your life.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: It does.
And now that I have
all these apps playing
on top of that Gmail layer that
do every little thing that I
need done, like Schedule Once.
That's my favorite.
That runs on top of my Gmail.
Scheduling probably saves
me 10 hours a week easily.
It's genius.
I love it.
KORY JEFFREY: It's kind
of like the unsexy ideas.
They kind of really get that.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: I know.
It's all about efficiency.
KORY JEFFREY: That's right.
Awesome.
Well, thank you very
much for joining us.
CHENOA FARNSWORTH: All right.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you guys for joining me.
We are at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]